and the three films nominated for best
achievement in visual effects are I was
fortunate enough to win an Oscar for
visual effects work in 1993 for the film
Death Becomes Her going to the Oscar
ceremony is both a very exciting and
very intimidating experience if you're
up for a nomination you're waiting for
your category to come up and you're fine
until about one event before your
category comes up and the Oscar goes to
and then the butterflies come and you
start wondering was my work really as
good as I thought it was are people
going to notice what I did Ken rollston
Doug Ching Doug Smite the Tom Withers Jr
but Death Becomes
Her your name gets called big relief and
now a different set of butterflies get
in cuz you have to make up to the front
on the stage you turn out at the theater
and you know you got the worldwide
audience and it's kind of intimidating
you know then again the adrenaline kicks
in and you it's almost a blur and I'd
like to thank everyone inm including
especially Gail Curry Lincoln who Judith
Weaver Andrew Schmidt Jeff Campbell Joe
Pasqual Brun Mullen Alex Sid J romman
and thank you Sandy carbon thank you
very
much after receiving the Oscar on stage
you're directed to a backstage area
first one just a more official sign your
name and then you go to The Press Room
and there's like several hundred members
of the press most of them have flash
bulbs going off and they're firing off
questions it's the kind of thing that
the audience is at home never get to see
it's pretty amazing experience I I will
never forget
[Music]
it